the audience questions have been pouring
in sort of like a fire hose and maybe
not surprisingly as we get closer to the
november election more and more
of the questions relate to the election
but not all of them the first one i got
is
how much of america will refuse the
coronavirus vaccine
and will this prevent us from getting to
herd immunity this is it's really an
empirical question it's not
i mean we can speculate about motives
and we can look at polling to figure out
part of the answer but part of this is
an empirical question in terms of
will we get to that magic number that we
need
in order to reach herd immunity now herd
immunity
there's a little bit of confusion about
herd immunity there are folks who email
me
and i can tell that they don't realize
the level of immunity to reach herd
immunity
depends on the disease so if a disease
is much
more contagious like for example measles
which has an
r value of somewhere between 16 and 18
i'm going from memory here measles is so
contagious
it spreads so easily where it can be
aerosolized where
you go into an elevator after someone
has already left the elevator
and they might have been carrying it and
you could catch it it's a huge level of
contagion far more than coronavirus or
the flu
it's so contagious that you need like 95
immunity to reach herd immunity which is
why it's so important that everybody be
vaccinated against measles
when the condition is less contagious
when the disease is less contagious
like coronavirus which is more
contagious than flu but far less
contagious than measles
the level of immunity required for herd
immunity is lower and
the estimates are that for coronavirus
it's about 70
rather than measles is 95 because
coronavirus spreads less easily than
measles
so we need to get to 70 now you can get
to that through a combination of
naturally acquired immunity from people
who have
recovered from the disease and
immunizations people who have been
vaccinated now there's an open question
as to how long
you are immune after recovering from
coronavirus
we don't know the answer to that yet but
hypothetically you could get your 70
percent
if five percent of the population has
recovered
naturally from coronavirus and
two-thirds you know 66
get vaccinated that gets you 71 you you
are at herd immunity
the sad reality of the situation is that
we have two polls one from
right around june one and one from july
one roughly
where only about half of americans say
they plan to get the vaccine
there's an ap norc poll from may 27
where 50 percent of americans say they
would get a coronavirus vaccine
and then june 30th on different poll
which
says that again about 50 percent of
americans plan to get the vaccine now
it's been five weeks since that latest
poll it's conceivable that because of
the continued
spread deaths back up to fifty you know
a thousand twelve hundred fifteen
hundred a day
that more people are now planning to get
the vaccine now this is simple math if
you need
seventy and half plan to get the vaccine
to get to herd immunity that means you
need an additional
twenty percent of the country to recover
naturally
twenty percent of the country is about
sixty six million people
uh that would imply a six hundred and
sixty thousand
person death toll estimating roughly one
percent
of those who get the virus die now
that's the simple math
the reality is when you look at more
complex and detailed contagion models
um you don't literally need 70
in for this reason and i want to try to
explain this
correctly um you aren't
re you don't come into contact with
everybody
in the country so in reality
your risk of contagion is not so much
about
is the country level at a country level
do we have 70 immunity
but it's more related to what's going on
in your immediate surroundings
and because we have dramatically
different urban versus rural or rural as
trump says
situations in the united states you
probably would get a
a practical practically speaking herd
immunity
somewhere short of 70 percent because
not the entire population is not
regularly coming into contact with the
entire population you're mostly coming
into contact with
some limited group of people when you're
going to work when you're going to your
grocery store etc and so the
the real number is a little short of 70
but regardless
if only half the country plans to get
the vaccine we need
20 to get the virus in order to reach
herd immunity and that means a lot of
people are going to die that would be
another 500 000 people compared to where
we are right now very very ugly
i hope that it's not the case i hope
people change their minds
but the polling so far is extremely
disturbing
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want
to sample a book before you buy the
entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video